i am raghavendran bioinformatics mentor
and research consultant with comics
logic let me brief you about my
my background and research interests
so i grew up to be a tinkerer kid who is
interested in solving many problems so
right in my younger ages computers and
programming with computers introduced me
to very new puzzles and challenges so
attempting to solve these puzzles and
these challenges were the first step
that took me towards solving puzzles and
asking questions so during my undergrad
education i read about the potential and
the announcement of the human genome
project
that
yeah and then that was the first
research article that i read i didn't
understand it most of it but it it
inspired me uh to a great deal and i
pursued my masters in biophysics so my
natural inclination towards computers
and structural biology bioinformatics
led me to specialization in
computational biology and bioinformatics
so uh after my master's in
bioinformatics uh biology biophysics
i joined phd in max plant institute uh
for biophysical chemistry uh with the
specialization in computational biology
so uh during this tenure i developed
software and designed a lot of
methodologies and pipelines for protein
structural and dynamic studies so my
system of interest during this during
the phd period was proteins associated
with neurodegenerative diseases
so uh when
at the time when the next gene
sequencing technologies
were starting to get established in
india i came back to india as a postdoc
to the institute of bioinformatics and
applied biotechnology in bangalore
the potential of the nitrogen sequencing
technique and its application to
multi-omics data analysis these two
combined and piqued my interest in
cancer so you all know
cancer is the leading cause of disease
death worldwide so uh i got naturally
inspired and uh
interested to work with cancer biology
so i contacted professor shanda ramadan
jnu and dr pedro ballister in in
collaboration with dr petri balaster in
insulin france
i proposed a study to understand and to
explore tumor responses to different
treatment achievements
so
this was while i was in bengaluru and i
also agreed to help a friend
who was in need of uh bioinformatics
help in
the dino
genome assembly of a variety of neem
plant so it was only during this
collaborative project i came to realize
how little information was available for
plant bioinformatics in the public
depositories while when you uh take or
when you compare it with the
availability of databases and the
repositories for human or bacteria
there is hardly anything for the plants
but there is so much potential to
understand
plant genetics because through
bioinformatics and through sequencing
techniques
we can understand the underlying biology
of plant genetics because agricultural
crops have been subjected to artificial
selection for ages irrespective of
geographical location irrespective of
culture
so i i continue to work with the project
and they are writing up the paper and
i'm still associated with the
department to uh for some
troubleshooting in the pipeline that i
developed
so while uh while all this was going on
the project that we proposed was
successfully funded and so i joined jnu
as a postdoctoral scientist
so uh i will detail more about the data
that i use for projects and and about
the projects and this is indeed uh
results in uh in a short but uh i just
wanted to mention right from my phds i
enjoyed working with undergrad students
and enjoyed working with students so
this experience tremendously inspires me
and i feel privileged to work with some
of the bright young minds
so i hope and i wish every one of you
will enjoy working with me and as much
as i look forward to working with you
so uh for the next two slides or the
next two slides i want to move on to
speak about the data that i use for the
project on precision oncology let's see
if i can get this yes okay great
so
every once in a while in in science that
the groundbreaking research gets
published and the data collected for
that work content contains a lot of
potential to answer a wide variety of
scientific questions and queries so this
is one such paper
and this paper is about tumor cells that
are grafted into mouse models uh to to
study uh tumor responses to different
treatment regimes so what they did was
they extracted the tumor cells from
cancer patients and then they uh they
sequenced it and from the sequence they
profiled at the gene expression levels
and the gene mutation levels and the
copy number variation levels and then
these tumor cells are grafted into
immunosuppressant mouse
so and these mouse were administered
different and
different set of treatment regimes
and and and
and the tumors response to these
treatment regimes were studied and such
mouse or such immunosuppressant mouse
which got administered with tumor grafts
are known as patient-derived xenografts
so these pdxs in short and they are
administered 60 different treatments and
and their response were recorded
in change in volume and the ability of
the mouse to survive the disease so such
survival data analysis of 1075 pdx mouse
was released along with this data along
with the study so this study from this
analysis concludes that the mouse models
provide a better alternative compared to
the cell lines which were traditionally
used because salines are often affected
by the petri dishes they have grown on
and heterogeneity is one of the biggest
problem in cell line data
so far
and
at the basic genomic level compared to
the cell lines the genes the
the gene expression levels of the pdxs
resemble more to the tran to the cancer
patients than the cell lines cell line
data
and
and
pdxs are also consistent or the data of
these pdxs are also consistent with
extensively studied therapies and
this comparison validates their
applicability to understand the
underlying cancer biology so such a
wealthy of data generates a breakthrough
of research questions as i already post
so one can employ this data to various
analytical pipelines to study treatment
stratification like can the mutations in
genomic data predict tumor resistance or
vice versa can tumor resistance uh
relate to significant mutations in those
models
are
our combination of drugs more effective
than single drugs or how how does
different combinations of drug work well
or does not work well together or can we
find the underlying biology behind this
or we can also do some precision
medicine study like
do targeted therapy exhibit higher
efficacy than general cytotoxic
treatments because
among these sixty treatments somewhere a
general cytotoxic treatments which are
toxic to all cells just they kill cancer
cells more than the normal cells and
some are
some specifically target pathways inside
the cancer cells so can we find out
the underlying differences between these
two treatments
and with the help of multi-omics
integration
can the pdx is broadly represent
the interpretation diversity because
that was one of the biggest conclusion
of this study where they observed
a diversity among the models which carry
the same cancer cells
from different patients so they
they translate into inter patient
diversity so can we quantify this
diversity or more importantly can we
find the commonality among this
diversity so that we can understand or
we can use it for biomarker analysis so
these are different questions and what
it i used to
i use this study to
work on so
my aim was to use this pdx data to
design and implement machine learning
models to predict human responses to
different treatment regimes and why do
we need to do that so the efficacy or
the effectiveness of the cancer drugs is
very strongly patient dependent that is
why we are moving more and more towards
precision oncology and personalized
medicine because on an average only 25
percentage of the cancer patients
actually respond to cancer drugs
but unlike unlike
your normal painkillers
you will have 80 percentage of the
patients responding positively to the
painkillers so currently there is a need
to predict which patient will respond
positively to the treatment and if not
there is no need to spend time and
energy and to treat the patients with
the treatment so
for this study one obviously cannot use
patient data because of
because of the difficulty in the
uniformity among the patient data but we
can actually use
these most model data to predict the
treatment response so how did i do that
the gene expression data the copy number
variation data and the gene mutation
data where the features from which the
machine learning models defines a
function to understand the tumor
response so when this model was
presented a test case it tries to
predict the tumor response to the
particular drug
so such a study this this model was
applied to breast cancer and colorectal
cancer pdxs which were treated for 26
different treatments
so what did we find
traditionally canonically
single genes were used as biomarkers
that predict the onset of cancer and the
same set of single genes were used as a
as a treatment biomarker also
for example
if if there is an association of a gene
to the onset of cancer the same gene was
studied whether this particular cancer
will respond positively or negatively to
any given treatment this is obviously
and
logically
is not a very accurate predictor so that
so this this is not a very successful
model but uh
from
from a very uh from the multi data
analysis what we
demonstrate is the
before that i want to uh before that i
want to introduce you to the accuracy
measure that we are measuring the tree
measuring the
machine learning model's
accuracy levels so this is matthew's
correlation coefficient where an
accuracy of one would mean the perfect
accuracy like all the test data or uh
perfectly uh
identified or predicted to be how it
responded to the treatment and -1 would
be complete opposite if there is a
positive response the model predicts a
negative
response and around 0 would be a random
response so what we want is these data
points to move more more towards one
so that we get better accuracy of our
machine learning model so uh
in that one so when the machine learning
model was
used used to predict on single gene
markers you see the accuracy is
not very great it is it's actually yeah
it's very bad
so
when multi-gene models were introduced
in place of single gene models the
accuracy is improved and the accuracy
level can further be improved by
combining or by including more than one
profiles or more than one molecular
profile like
gene mutation data combined with
gene expression data combined with copy
number variation data improves accuracy
tremendously so to quantify we actually
observed we could predict
19 out of 26
treatment regimes
we could predict correctly 19 out of 26
treatment regimes so
this was what we performed and what
could be done what could be done more in
in such a study so one can extend such
an analysis to include patient data from
tcga repository but that involves
extensive curation of the data but one
can still do it
a gene set enrichment analysis like what
oja presented
of the biomarker genes will throw
insight into the biology behind the
response of these tumors to different
treatment levels so uh
this is how we did and
such a study was actually performed for
selected cancer and for selected
treatments so one can obviously extend
the study to all the cancer to find the
commonality of these cancer cells to
react to different treatment regimes
so these are the different
future steps that the team is currently
working on but i finished my part and i
joined for mixed logics
so i hope this project was informative
and it does inspire you to utilize
curated pdx data this curated pdx data
will be available at the omixlogix
platform shortly and this
yeah
this platform as you are aware by now
with uh different uh introduction from
elia and from uh
and from sonalika provides a very well
organized research fellowship program
that i want to speak about in the next
two slides
let me go to the next slide so yes so
from my research experience there are
three main challenges that all
researchers will need to overcome in any
research program and this research
program is designed to target
specifically to address these
one
time so a lot of time is actually spent
on learning research methods from
multiple sources with the varying level
of reliability but in the end you are
going to use only one or two methods for
your question of interest so what we
have the the learning platform the omics
logic learning platform provides you
with a very well planned learning
modules and coursework this coursework
will prepare you for any challenges you
might face with the data analysis and or
the biological interpretation of your
data analysis and your research question
and
another big challenge in doing
computational work or bioinformatics
work is
is the presence of or is rather there is
a limited access to bioinformatics
expertise or a reduced availability to
bioinformatics experts
for the students so
with
in this program the research fellows
will participate in cutting-edge
bioinformatics research led by mentors
like me
like harpreet and several other mentors
you will find information in the website
we have years of expertise in
computational biology bioinformatics and
also including emerging domains like
spaceomics so this network of mentors
that we have will provide you with
expert feedback and peer review from the
inception of your topic to the final
results and these results will be worthy
to be sharing among the scientific
community and to the world
and and one final challenge is limited
access to infrastructure that is
required to perform big data analysis
this is i think this is the most
important challenge that
many students face right now
so uh
the cloud-based analytical turbo
bioinformatics platform that you are
introduced to today it provides all the
infrastructure that is necessary to
perform big data analysis in an
intuitive environment with the help of
flexible interactive and visual
pipelines so the research fellows will
get access to this platform and a list
of curated public data sets with which
you can design a big data analytics
pipeline or multi-umix data or one can
perform translation research or one can
address clinical questions or biomarker
identification or treatment
certification or variety of questions
that you can think about leveraging this
data and infrastructure
so who can benefit from such a research
fellowship program
so
this research fellowship program has
been designed to help young research and
students like you to gain access to the
premium resources on bioinformatics for
the analysis of complex high throughput
data sets that i presented before and uh
like dr harpith also presented and also
we
observed from oja also so
and the experts will help you complete a
research study on your own so if you are
an undergraduate or a master's student
you can actually engage in research and
you can develop a deeper understanding
of the subject matter than that is
possible through uh through your
classroom routines or classroom
instructions alone so such an early
exposure to research has been proven to
be very helpful and can ah can be the
perfect launchpad for your carrier you
can also apply the skills that is that
is that is one of the most important
point you can apply all the skills
practically the skills that you learn
from your classroom instructions to a
project of your own and to the project
of your
that peaks your interest
and and more um
[Music]
documentation wise you can fulfill the
requirements set by your university uh
said by your university syllabus or
curriculum so if you are a research
student so we provide
you will get an excellent opportunity to
work one-on-one with the network of
mentors and to use the tbio big data
infrastructure to be part of your
research question or to be an
independent study to develop new skills
that ever interested you interested to
do that so